these demonstrators in Bangkok are
demanding elections after a day of calm
in the thai capital protesters are back
on the streets defying the military's
ban on gatherings supporters of the
ousted government to voicing their
outrage over the military coup and the
imposition of martial law we're here to
express ourselves but the soldiers are
trying to arrest us they're trying to
silence us Thailand's military has taken
a series of tough measures since seizing
power on Thursday it's curbed civil
liberties restricted the media and
suspended the constitution
crew leaders have also detained more
than 150 politicians including deposed
Prime Minister Yingluck Shinawatra G in
a number of her political allies have
been taken to an unknown location the
Army says it plans to hold them for up
to a week you'll be found that there is
no significantly and no lling at all to
the conflict and they'd be able to find
a common ground and and I'm sick for a
common understanding among those person
regarding how to resolve the situation
in the country we would release them for
sure two leaders have also some in
dozens of outspoken academics a
nighttime curfew remains in place